[Musique]
avant que la vidéo commence je voulais
vous informer qu'un concours pour gagner
un pendentif live earth et est
disponible sur mon discorde disponible
en descriptions donc voilà si vous
voulez participer n'hésitez pas allez le
voir que la vidéo commence à ça faisait
un moment que je voulais faire cette
vidéo je suis un fan de la licence final
fantasy mais quand je dis fans ses
limites maladif et la fantaisie 15 est
un jeu qui fut beaucoup critiqué mal
aimé adoré
on possède de nombreux défauts mais
aussi de très grande qualité et bon sens
qu'il m'a marqué un vrai final fantasy
anciennement final fantasy versus xiii
j'ai envie de vous parler de ff 15 un
grand final fantasy à mes yeux et sans
tarder voici les trois théories que je
vous propose
[Musique]
comme vous le savez final fantasy 15 est
composé de plusieurs donjons pour la
plupart optionnel à l'histoire
néanmoins un donjon marque les esprits
des joueurs et cache de nombreux secrets
pour cette première théorie je veux vous
parler des ruines de pitié hausse située
au nord du volcan de rabat gots ce
donjon est le plus compliqué que j'ai
jamais vu sans parler du fait qu'il soit
très très bien caché bref contrairement
aux autres donjons celui ci est très
développé et le background de ce temple
peut nous révéler bien des secrets
malheureusement tout est théorique car
le l'or sur le background de ff 15 n'a
pas été vraiment développé à mon plus
grand regret sans plus tarder voici la
tragique histoire des ruines de pitié
hausse tout d'abord décortiquons le mot
pitiot ce qui voudrait dire pitt off et
hausse soit en français le gouffre des
os
nous sommes donc dans les ruines du
gouffre des hausses mais savez-vous qui
était au saumon et hausse est le nom
donné à la région de final fantasy 15 et
ce nom proviendrait de la déesse
principal de ff 15 justement eos
cependant cette dernière fut bannie dans
les plus profonds des ruines de pitch
hausse d'où son nom
pourquoi et au sort a été bannie dans
les profondeurs pour avoir eu une
relation avec humain ce qui aurait donc
créé la lignée du lucie ce soit donc une
lignée de demi dieu
après tout leur pouvoir peuvent en
témoigner mais ce n'est que théorique
bien sûr suite à ceux ci ifrit furieux
aurait voulu libérer et hausse de ce
gouffre mais je ne saurais dire pourquoi
car peut-être qu'ils frites et météo ça
c'est possible
les ruines de pitié hausse nous montre
la descente des frites dans ce gouffre
pour tenter de libérer et hausse notre
chemin avec nos petits dans ce donjon
retracerait donc son parcours
cependant comme vous le savez ifrit
fugue banny aussi des six pour sa haine
envers les humains et c'est là que la
partie intéressante commence lorsque
vous entrez dans le donjon une statue
les frites est enfermé dans une cage
symbolisant donc son bannissement et
notre statut énorme d'un dieu tenant la
porte afin de surveiller kéos ne sortent
pas du kif
nous allons parler de lui un petit peu
après
avancez et suivez le chemin dit frites
jusqu'à la fin du donjon mais comme
attendu et hausse est morte dans ce
gouffre et c'est à ce moment qu'ils
frites aurait donc péter un plomb il
fait est connu dans ff 15 pour haïr les
humains et pour pouvoir lancer le star
secours ge qui est la maladie des
étoiles transformant les humains en
diamonds
ce serait pour ça qu'ils seraient
qualifiés de traîtres ifrit fou de rage
de la mort des hausses auraient donc
fait énormément de mal au monde
notamment à cause de cette maladie
dénicher dans les profondeurs des ruines
de pitié hausse pour en revenir à la
statue justement le dieu tenant la porte
serait en fait titan l'un des six dieux
de la terre ce qui semble logique mais
comme vous savez titan est bloqué par un
météore qu'il s'est pris en plein centre
des os et bien c'est à cause dit frites
quand il a lancé le stage courges et
meteor sont arrivés sur la terre
apportant la maladie nous avons la
preuve avec les ruines le dieu tenant la
porte se prend un boulet sur la tête qui
l'a cassera les bouley sont les
métaphores des météores dans les ruines
exactement comme titan tenant son meteor
sur les épaules qu'il s'est pris il ya
plusieurs siècles déjà il était donc
celui qui amena le mal sur terre et fut
considéré comme traître
mais la théorie ne s'arrête pas là vers
la fin du donjon qui est un réel en
faire à finir j'ai mis quatre heures
personnellement c'est horrible vous
arrivez sur la statue des os qui est
enchaîné et vous la fait de tomber pour
accéder à la suite
cependant un détail intrigue énormément
lorsque la statue est couché dirigez
vous vers le ventre des os et au niveau
du nombril vous pourrez ramasser un
objet plutôt particulier les gangs angie
outre le fait que ce sont des
équipements d'exception genji en
japonais voudrait dire tout beginning
soit 2 commencement et hausse suite à sa
relation avec un humain sur terre
auraient donc été enceinte et aurait
donné naissance à des jumeaux ce qui
aurait créé la lignée du cices dotée de
grands pouvoirs maintenant devinez qui
fut le premier roi désigné du lu 6 bien
sûr nous parlons bien de hard
hardin serait le descendant est le fils
d os elle même hardin était un homme bon
un homme maîtrisant les pouvoirs de la
lumière il soignait les gens mais fut
écarté du trône à cause des parasites
qui l'avaient inspiré pour soigner les
gens
il ne fut donc pas reconnu par le
cristal et la lignée de noctis est donc
apparu cependant hardin aurait donc un
frère jumeau cela voudrait dire je suis
incapable de vous dire qui beaucoup
mentionne le nom 18 n'ya que porte
hardin certains parlent de bahamut mais
se serait-il logique et d'autres parlent
de la descendance de noctis
ce serait le plus probable hardin serait
le frère de la descendance de noctis le
second enfant des os
enfin pour terminer cette théorie tout
ceci expliquerait donc une partie du
combat final de final fantasy 15 ifrit
aurait donc rejoint harding car il est
le fils des hausses celle qu'il a voulu
libérer et donc se venger des humains et
des six qu'ils l'auraient enfermée et
trahi
à son tour il est loin le temps du petit
prince faible et ignorants voyons ce que
tu vaux main
encore loi j'espère que
ne sera pas
à
[Musique]
bien
sinon ça
[Musique]
en parcourant de nombreux forums pour en
savoir plus sur l'histoire mal exploité
le ff 15 quelque chose m'est venue à
l'esprit
et si erding n'était pas si mauvais
laissez-moi m'expliquer tout d'abord que
savons-nous d'art dean par dean était un
roi du lu 6 2000 ans avant ff 15
il soigne et le peuple en absorbant leur
maladie il était quelqu'un de bon être
le roi de la lumière et de par le
cristal était donc la chose logique il
devait arriver
cependant ils furent rejetées par le
cristal car jugé trop un pur et tout ça
pour quoi
à cause des maladies qu'il absorbait
pour soigner les gens les parasites que
contenait son corps suite à ses bonnes
actions longtemps empêché de devenir roi
de la lumière et hardin fut donc écartés
du trône puis exécuté mais les parasites
qu'il avait absorbé le rendre immortel
et il en profitera pour retourner sa
veste et monte son plan de machiavélique
et devint chancelier de niflheim grâce à
ses grands talents de manipulateur
nous sommes donc maintenant deux mille
ans plus tard toute cette histoire est
la maladie transformant les gens dimon
s'est répandue hardin s'en servira mais
bref là n'est pas la question
hardin et donc chancelier de niflheim et
se servira de son statut pour se
rapprocher de noctis et l'aider oui les
des taux le long de l'aventuré
hardin n noctis à devenir roi de la
lumière il le conduira jusqu'à las
nodules u6 au cristal et à la force des
dieux noctis n'aurait jamais pu y
arriver sans hardin pourquoi fait-il
ceci alors hardin possède des pouvoirs
incommensurables anciens rois du lys et
plus de 2000 ans de vécu
je vous raconte pas la puissance qu'ils
possèdent et surtout quand le monde est
plongé dans les ténèbres
il aurait pu écraser noctis maintes fois
et pourtant il ne l'a pas fait il l'a
même aidé ordina aidé à propulser
niflheim jusqu au pouvoir suprême
il savait que c'était les rivaux du 8 6
mais il les a tout de même tué par la
suite
l'empereur ou même rave us vous allez me
dire que c'est normal
hardin voulait le pouvoir pour lui tout
seul ce qui est vrai mais hardy n'en est
en fait nettoyer le terrain pour notice
comme ça il n'aurait plus d'ennemis en
arrivant sur le trône car oui hardin
aide noctis à s'asseoir sur le trône
hardin est quelqu'un de très intelligent
et souhaitait juste se venger ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'il a tout
manigancé depuis le début mais pas comme
nous le pensions il a pris sa revanche
en tuant tout le monde je l'admets mais
il a comme qui dirait purifier le monde
prenons l'exemple du fritz hardin
savaient qu'ils frites perdrait et ils
étaient une menace pour les humains il
dit même à noctis dose attend en preuve
du fait qu'il savait que noctis vaincre
est ifrit et du coup le ferait
disparaître du monde et au moment du
combat final hardy ne tue pas prompte à
ig nice et gladio luce alors qu'il le
pouvait pourquoi après tout les
massacres qu'il a fait normalement il
veut faire souffrir noctis et le tuer
sauvagement enfin hardy n'utilise qu'une
petite partie de ses pouvoirs pendant le
combat final
comme je disais il a des pouvoirs
incommensurables suite à ces deux mille
ans de vécu et ses pouvoirs du roi
il aurait donc dû détruire nos petits
mais bon et il l'a même aidé à se former
pour la bataille
hardin aurait fait un dernier acte de
bonté avant de mourir en purifiant le
monde
ils savaient qu'ils perdraient et tout
ce qu'il voulait au final s'était reposé
en paix et aurait laissé noctis le tuer
cardyn aurait finalement accepté son
sort
il aurait accepté le fait d'être
l'incarnation de la nuit de la maladie
transformant les gens en deuil mais
je ne sais pas si vous avez compris ma
pensée merdy n'était quelqu'un de bon à
la base les meilleurs méchants sont
souvent les plus grands gentils c'est
une autre façon de voir harding mais
cette théorie marcherait mieux synopsis
était en vie à la fin mais en moins est
il réellement mort
[Musique]
la question la plus récurrente de final
fantasy 15 est-ce que noctis est mort à
la fin du jeu ou bien at il survécu
je vais vous répondre personnellement la
question cette théorie est donc
complètement subjective comme la
précédente
je vous avoue que la question n'est pas
vraiment facile et que je suis
réellement partagé entre la mort et la
vie
mais essayons tout de même de trouver
une réponse même si elle peut être
fausse
attention tout d'abord noctis moeurs
réellement à la fin de l'histoire
il le sait de lui même il n'a pas le
choix s'il veut vaincre hardin et le
détruire ses compagnons le savent aussi
nos petits se laisse donc partir comme
un roi en invoquant les anciens rois du
lui six dont son père il se laisse
emporter dans l'au-delà pour une
dernière fois des faits rares dean qui
peut encore potentiellement revenir il
se transforme même comme les autres rois
du lys une sorte d'âme puis disparaît
montrant bien qu'il est mort le monde
redevient alors comme il était comme
sous un nouveau jour la lumière revient
néanmoins suite à cette cinématique
contre toute attente noctis réapparaît
dans la salle du trône en compagnie de
luna freya regardant la photo qu'il a
choisi comme souvenir prouvant encore
une fois qu'ils savaient qu'il mourrait
et voulait emporter une photo qui lui
tenait à coeur
alors pourquoi comment se fait-il qu'ils
soient revenus les créateurs de ce final
fantasy savent que c'est une question
difficile à répondre
ils l'ont fait exprès bref à supposer
que nos petits soit réellement mort
régis en cerveau a dû lui 6 et père de
noctis remercie luna et son fils pour
avoir ramené la lumière et il a fait en
sorte qu'ils se retrouvent et soient
heureux ensemble
nous pensons donc à une sorte de paradis
et les bras et a retrouvé toute sa
splendeur
tous les bâtiments sont restaurés et la
salle du trône et décoré et le décor est
fait de telle sorte qu'on penserait un
mariage ce qui accentue le côté paradis
de la chose à noter que noctis et luna
apparaissent ensemble comme par magie
dans l'endroit sans oublier que tout est
vide il n'y a personne
aucun personnage tout ceci accentue le
côté mortifère de la scène noctis et
luna sont morts et point barre beaucoup
le pensent
même le bec du lu 6 disparaît tout est
fait pour nous faire penser ceci
mais
mon coeur pensent le contraire et j'ai
envie de vous expliquer pourquoi
tout d'abord où bras le chien qui élit à
noctis et surtout luna c'est un détail
très important
notre voyons seule couche et au pied du
bâtiment royal restant là où son maître
l'a quitté et tout d'un coup on bras
semble ressentir quelque chose nous le
voyons à son mouvement de tête comme
s'il avait senti que noctis et luna
était revenu et bien évidemment noctis
réapparaît en compagnie de luna en quoi
ce détail est important
douna freya possède un deuxième chien
qui lui est lié et lorsque cette
dernière fut tué prina s'est laissée
mourir
étant donné que sa maîtresse n'était
plus de ce monde prénat est morte et ne
réapparaît pas à la fin alors comme bras
lui est bien vivant et attend patiemment
je n'irais pas jusqu'à dire qu'il savait
que noctis et luna reviendrai mais il
est bien vivant
il n'a pas été tué il était resté à
hammerhead avant de se diriger vers
tenebrae ensuite la scène de fin nous
montre le monde comme s'il était
restaurée revenus peut-être même dans le
passé pour reprendre un nouveau départ
et le deuxième détail qui me titille
sont les quatre chaises que nous voyons
montrant bien que quatre protagonistes
sont passés par là pour camper vous
voyez de qui je veux parler
cela nous montre bien que les compagnons
de noctis sont là quelque part et qu'ils
ont continué leur vie après la
disparation de noctis
nous sommes donc bien dans le monde réel
de ff 15 puis un argument me fait aussi
penchés en cette faveur
c'est que nous sommes dans un final
fantasy chaque final fantasy se finit
globalement bien surtout pour personnage
principal
pas la peine de mettre final fantasy
tease dans les commentaires car fm 10,2
et là pour l'apn
régis n'a pas supporté la mort de son
fils quand il s'est laissé partir en
tant que dernier roi du lu 6 il ne
voulais pas le tuer cela se voyait
et lui tournait même le dos pour moi
régis serait donc communiquer avec les
autres anciens rois pour ramener nos
petits c'est luna ayant sauvé le monde
des ténèbres
les anciens rois sont immortels et
possède de grands pouvoirs
et se pourrait même qu'il possède le
pouvoir de vie et de mort
après tout il peut faire mourir des
personnes par le biais de l'anneau donc
pourquoi pas le message de régis à la
fin n'est pas là par hasard et serait
donc comme un message de remerciement et
pour annoncer que vous avez donc le
droit de vivre heureux et revenir vivre
votre vie
régis aurait convaincu les autres rois
du lu 6 de leur ramener
et puis tenebrae se doit avoir un roi
pour diriger nos petits ce permet de
continuer la lignée des lucides kaloum
et cela expliquerait aussi pourquoi luna
serai là pour finir pour expliquer le
fait que la salle du trône soit décoré
serait pour moi que gladio luce iggy
nice et prompte au soir venu pour
honorer noctis là où il est décédé
avec un étendard portant son nom complet
et les fleurs que l'on amène
symboliquement sur la tombe d'un mort ou
pour honorer et se remémorer de
quelqu'un
le retour de la lumière rend la pièce
même encore plus belle enfin la photo et
le dernier argument clé la photo est
resté là où nos petits cela laissait ne
pouvant peut-être pas l'emporter dans
l'au delà
la photo est resté là où nos petits ce
fut tué dans le monde réel comme bras
tout ceci indiquerait d'après moi que
noctis serait vivant s'il ne l'est pas
et vu la campagne portée pour final
fantasy 15 attendez vous un ff 15,2 un
jour ou l'autre
à noter que noctis était accompagné des
cinq dieu régnant sur le monde ils
étaient leurs élus il se pourrait que
ces derniers en est pour quelque chose
dans le retour de noctis en tout cas
n'oubliez pas que ce sont des théories
surtout la dernière qui est le plus
grand débat sur ce jeu elle est sûrement
fausse mais je voulais vous partager ma
vision final fantasy 15 est un jeu qui
m'a marqué je suis un fan incontesté de
la licence cela en est même maladif et
c'est pour ça que j'ai créé ma chaîne
secondaire à propos de celle ci ff 15
possède de gros défaut je le reconnais
j'ai été moi même déçu du passage du
chapitre 9 au chapitre xiv trop expédia
mon goût mais au final c'est là que je
me rends compte que cette petite
déception sur ce passage est bonne car
elle nous prouve que nous voulions en
savoir plus que nous étions à fond dans
ce ff 15 et qui nous a transportés pour
moi et chef 15 est un chef-d'oeuvre
parmi les autres opus de la saga émérite
notre considération et fait 15 a su
montrer ce qu'ils avaient dans le ventre
et on ne peut que lui reprocher de ne
pas nous avoir donné plus mais c'est
humain après tout nous voulons toujours
plus n'ai jamais eu autant de frissons
que dans ce jeu et pourtant tout le
monde sait que j'ai fait fuiter mon
préféré
alors les amis j'espère que ces théories
vous auront plus final fantasy à jamais
dans mon coeur merci à ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo n'hésitez pas à me
suivre sur twitter pour les plus
acharnés d'entre vous que le 'lion'
alors soit avec vous et surtout souvenu
vous gardez la tête aux portes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
merci